hey everybody happy New Year it's 20
[__] 24 can you believe that I can't
believe that I don't care yeah it's not
like it makes a difference they're all
the same they're all the same yeah
that's the spirit I'm trying to ignore
them no yeah I mean it is they are kind
of all the same kind of like birthdays
ignore that [__] well like I said
birthdays are good CU you get presents
and cake I don't care about getting I
don't take them to heart though no I
don't either there are too many of them
yeah they start stacking up they start
stacking up they start stacking up on
you you're like God damn sure yeah all
right um is is Zan is here hooray yeah
zanada sent me this movie wanted me to
review it I have seen this movie before
but a long time ago yeah I saw this Pro
I don't think I saw it in the theater
but I think I saw it as soon as it came
out on D DD or whatever so Allstar cast
got Johnny depps in it playing 100 S
Thompson Johnny Depp is great at yeah
he's [__] great it's got bisho Del
Toro I love him I love him in everything
playing he's playing Hunter S Thompson's
lawyer what was his name yeah well Dr
Gonzo in the movie but he's based on a
real guy but you know yeah and uh some
of us some have criticize the movie that
there's no story oh no there's a story
there's a [__] story we talking about
this is a drug Adventure this was a drug
Adventure comedy these two crazy
[__] that were real people in
real life or actually like you said Dr
Gonzo might have just been based he was
based on a real guy but that wasn't a
composite of any of no it was based on a
real person based on a real person named
um Oscar Zeta akat yeah and uh who was
indeed a lawyer yeah and then his friend
Hunter Hunter Thompson who was going
journalist ra Duke yeah he was a
journalist but he was kind of like an
outlaw journalist he did a lot of
[__] cool [__] in his time uh got
into a lot of trouble uh this is back
when journalists did [__] but he'd get
so high he'd forget he he'd forget to do
the job he forgot and he'd just come up
with a new
story but uh this is a great flick if
you've ever done a bunch of LSD or
gotten really [__] hammered you will
totally relate to this uh this is about
the time they go
to Las Vegas and just get really [__]
up and do all the drugs that have ever
been invented in the history get into
all kinds of [__] trouble and they
try to get out of the trouble the
trouble includes underage girls who try
to [__] L which was worse in real
life the event was worse they kind of
softened it a bit for yeah the girls
played by Christina REI a kind of a more
grown Christina REI I forgotten she was
in this movie yeah this is when she
first she got real voluptuous she wasn't
that little skinny girl anymore she was
curvy she looked good thought thought
she looked great little short she still
looks real young in this yeah she's real
young probably about 17 18 yeah um and
then uh [__] man [__] Gary booy's in
it plays a cop that needs a kiss you
know what I heard I heard that that line
which was which made me bust up laughing
because I forgot about that line that
whole thing where Gary Bucy pulls over
uh you know raw duke or whatever Hunter
homson and the last thing he says is
like ask him for a little kiss it's like
he gets lonely out here and stuff like
that apparently Gary Bucy like ad libed
that did he yeah yeah and was crazy when
Hunter S Thompson saw the movie he's
like man I would never say nothing like
that but Terry Gilliam the director
thought it was so funny that he left it
in there which I mean glad he left it in
there cuz that [__] is
funny CU iy said that though yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's what I said oh okay but
Hunter S Thompson didn't say it no okay
but he said he'd never say he said that
cop would never said that no yeah he
said that you know he yeah he just said
that that didn't happen that didn't
happen like that or whatever it was
crazy though it's good that they left it
in there I know cuz it was just like so
random that was like one of the best fck
[__] the cops going off on him at the
end he goes can I have a kiss I get
lonely it's just like so out of field
and I just like I totally forgot cuz
like I said I saw this movie a long time
ago I think I saw it whenever whenever
it first came out on DVD I think I
rented it so what was that 2000 maybe
199 2000 yeah and this is the uh the
first first time I had ever heard
somebody mentioned it adrenochrome ever
mentioned yeah that it came from
pituitary glads of kids terrified kids
that they got it from a Satanist yeah
they were taking it I don't know if
that's true uh it doesn't sound it
sounds very satanic panicky but it's not
impossible I guess the thing is though
is you know like I said iic hormones and
synthetic hormones if there's going to
get something out of a pituitary gland
those hormones are not gonna stay
they're not gonna have a real short
halflife there's got to be some kind of
way to get those to chemically fix
themselves so you could actually use
them in some way that sounds like a tall
tail and usually what ends up happening
in like biochemistry and the
manufacturer of
drugs it's far more efficient to
synthetically
produce that hormone in a laboratory
than it is to get it out of a gland yeah
I mean because that would be a huge yeah
it's just it's better to just know what
the molecule looks like and then you use
chemical processes to make it and then
you do something like give it an Esther
which is like carbon shells around it so
it so it can stay in in in in storage
and when you put it in your body it'll
last for a long time instead of it just
Fizzles most of those hormones like if
you were just inject pure testosterone
into your body like from one person to
another in an hour it would be gone it
just doesn't have any staying power you
know what I mean it's meant to be
produced on site and used on site so the
adrenaline the the the Aden Chrome story
sounds like a wild Tale and that tail
kind of lives on there's some people in
the conspiracy circles think that
they're harvesting adrenic Chrome out of
little
kids and then using it and say say it
sounds unlikely it's easier just to make
that
[__] yeah that's what I mean a lot of
unless you were just unless it was like
some super super Fringe thing where
people were doing it just for the kicks
because they wanted it out of a real
person yeah a little kid um that if you
were just going to sell the drug like
for profit which most people would then
yeah it would be Hoy to
or if you're just going to use it yeah
you know you're using it it and much
less chance of getting like left in
prison or yeah most of that stuff's made
out of commonly available materials you
just have to know the
recipe so uh but anyway it's still a
great flick it has a bunch of [__]
weird [__] that happens into you like
wait hold on are they doing that or are
you hallucinating it's very kind of
mindbending you try to keep track of
what's real and what isn't real real
sometimes and uh you forget what they're
doing because they forget what they're
doing yeah there's all kinds of weird
[__] there was now the thing about this
is that this is a fairly which is crazy
to say they've been trying to they had
been trying to make a film of this movie
like I since at least the early 90s
maybe earlier you know um Oliver Stone
wanted to do it Martin scores he wanted
to do it um Ralph bakshi wanted to do it
the guy that does all the um the
animated like Hobbit and Lord of the
Rings and stuff like he wanted to do it
and he wanted to make an animated film
which I saw another review of that and
they were like wanted to make an
animated fil like well you know what
that might have worked I'm not really
sure maybe somebody could do that one of
these days that might be kind of cool
but I think even though Terry Gilliam
was one of the you know kind of not the
first choice of director I think for a
time they were going to get Alex Cox to
do it um but which you know that might
have worked to but I don't know but
Terry Gilliam I think was maybe in
hindsight like the perfect person to do
this
because the book
is if you see this movie it's a pretty
accurate representation of the book as
as far as you could do that you know
what I mean they did take some stuff out
that wasn't really gerine to like the
center plot of like the two main
characters just to keep it from going
all over the place more than it already
does but some of the stuff in that movie
was like exactly how he described in the
book like they even took passages and
dialogue and stuff like that directly
from the book so they tried to make it
like accurate and like I said this is
crazy it's visually really good movie
too yeah and and if you notice every
time every time they went on a different
drug because they went on a whole
Adventure you know what I mean like with
different drugs and stuff the
cinematographer would change up the
lenses and the lighting and stuff like
that to make it like the more accurate
to like what the experience would be
like actually being on that which I
thought was a great [__] idea yeah
cuz October rth said it really visually
is the closest thing I've ever seen to
what it's really like on 10 hits of 7s
acid I know I lived it I think and
particularly that one scene where he
goes and tries to check into the hotel
and it's like the bar and then like
everybody's giant lizards you know what
I mean like all the faces are stretching
and the carpet's going all weird and
stuff like that um yeah I think they did
a good job with that but yeah I was
goingon to say that Johnny Depp
actually because he wasn't the first
actor that was picked for this either I
think John Cusack was going to do it
because he had actually directed A play
um of this of the book and um so he was
kind of attached for a little while they
actually I think they wanted Jack
Nicholson and Marlon
Brando but by well by the time they got
around to making the movie they were
like well they're too old they been too
old obviously Marlin brand you wouldn't
have been able to control him well that
might have it might have worked out I
don't know but to be considering but
really I think they got the perfect cuz
you know Johnny Depp it's like I've seen
him in St stuff some stuff that I
thought he was annoying and [__] like
that but he's really good he Nails this
and the reason he Nails it is because he
lived with Hunter S Thompson in his
basement for four months oh I didn't
know that yeah um prior to do and he
read all of his old notes and he went
through all his and all the clothes and
jewelry and stuff you see him wearing
that's that's all Hunter real [__] like
he let him wear it um he drove his car
the great red shark or whatever they
called it he's like he drove that around
for 4 months cuz they traded cars now
there's something funny about I want to
say about this
character you get to in this movie you
get to see um
you you get to see [__] what's his
name confuse
me [__] well who are you talking about
the guy who played Hunters Thompson just
on tip of my tongue Johnny Johnny Depp
yeah you get to see a young good really
goodl looking Johnny Depp he's he's in
his prime right and he's bald in this
he's rocking the
[__] [__] receding hairline he's
just got hair on the side he's wearing
the old man hats the [__] glasses
yeah those are actually all and and
Hunter S Thompson cut Johnny Depp's hair
cuz Hunter S Thompson had male pattern
baldness that wasn't a haircut yeah so
he cut it I heard the story I heard was
that he cut it in his bathroom while
wearing um a 's helmet with a lamp on it
yeah yeah that's the story I heard I
know if that's true it's funny to see
Johnny Depp with that hair yeah he's
still good looking but it's just CU he
was still pretty young I mean he was
still pretty young is yeah you always
imagine him you know Johnny de [__]
full head of hair you know [__]
basically [__] male heartthrob type
characters you know like but this guy
he's just this wacky [__] reporter or
you know
journalist wearing some what's funny is
that he's wearing clothes that we
associate with an old guy but really
that old guy was wearing those when he
was young so that's why we associated
with old by the because they were still
wearing those clothes when they got old
when they got old they were still
dressed like that so dress like that
it's just funny to see a young guy
dressed like that yeah but uh it's great
man he he does a great job in that role
everybody does a great job Toby Toby
McGuire shows up in it he's a kid in it
I had forgotten basically and his hair
is also crazy in this he's got like a
receding hairline and this like thin
white blond like long hair and stuff
he's only in it for like 2 minutes like
he plays this hitchhiker that they he
does a good job though his his whole job
is just to have these [__] up
Expressions because he doesn't know what
he does know what the [__] he was just
hitchhike and it got picked up by these
guys [__] nuts that are on like all
that have okay so the the story behind
this movie if you don't know so the book
uh came out in 1971 Hunter Thompson very
famously was a they uh kind of founded
Gonzo journalism which is kind of you
know how prior to that like if you were
in the media or you were you were a
journalist you were supposed to remain
like objective you know what I mean and
not become part of the story but like
Gonzo journalism was kind of like you
jumped in and you became part of the
[__] you know what I mean so that's kind
of what this is and
ostensibly he was sent to Vegas to cover
it's like it was like a motorcycle race
right like motorcycles and dune buggies
like M 400 but very quickly oh well I
mean before they even got there him and
Dr Gonzo who you know in real life was
his uh friend Oscar they um said yeah
we're going to go out to Vegas to cover
this race and they rented this red was
it a Cadillac it was a white C no it was
a Chevy Impala it was a Chevy Impala it
was a um convertible the Cadillac they
have was white yeah yeah that's right
but the the red one they rented so
they're going to drive out to the desert
and and they bring a
humongous suitcase of drugs all kinds of
drugs of all different descriptions yeah
and they're basically going
to kind of the theme of it if there's a
theme of anything is they're trying to
find the heart of the American dream I
guess so the thing about it is that when
they were first talking about making
this movie and when Terry Gilliam was
first kind of like attack to it he said
that the producers wanted him to update
the book to the 9s like you know to the
Contemporary time when the movie was
made and he's like that would have been
a really see you know that would have
been a stupid idea yeah it would because
he's like yeah he's like if you made it
in the 90s it would just be two guys
going ape [__] like on drugs like big
deal but he's like you know what I mean
if you said it in
1971 you know with the backdrop of like
the end of hippie culture and like the
Vietnam War and all that kind of stuff
it's like suddenly you get this kind of
you know like I said end of the American
dream kind of thing where it wouldn't
have had that same cultural resonance
had you said it in the 9s like you said
it just would have been two people going
batet on all the drugs yeah and doing
crazy [__] but you know it's it's funny
like it's a funny movie but I imagine
that if you had to deal with the two of
them oh man like Hest that would have
been a [__] nightmare cuz there's
some bad [__] like toward the end
because there's one scene in there and
even Terry gilam said that um you know
he wanted this to be kind of their low
point where they go into that Diner and
they're basically threatening that
waitress yeah yeah you know what I mean
she thought she was going to get robbed
and raped or something yeah which was
like which is horrible yeah so you so
the the reason they left that scene in
there was because he's like well I mean
that really did happen and he's like and
I wanted to show that this was like
their low Point they' like gone beyond
the pale you know what I mean yeah well
they were suffering from basically brain
exhaustion too I mean their their brains
were pretty fried they had been doing
[__] a lot of drug drugs for a long
period of time by that time so they
weren't in their right Minds The Brain
clearly not I don't even know how they
were
yeah the one one of the funniest scenes
to me too is like when they first I
don't even remember what what this right
after they took the
ether and then they started going into
that one casino that was like it's
supposed to be Circus Circus but the
real Casino wouldn't let them film in
there so they had to like make like a
mockup um and they're like walking like
super crazy like they're all like their
legs are like all like that and they're
just like oh they have no [__] idea
what so it was a real story about the
girl they they come up the Dude shows up
with his girl uh do what's his name Dr
gono Dr gono shows some girl and she's
got all these paintings of uh barbar
barrian she came all the way out to
Vegas to meet bar she ran away evidently
she's underage and he's kind of taking
care of her he gave her some acid but
then uh and she yeah I don't know how
old she was supposed to be but hunter
shows up he's like no man we got got to
get rid of her this is bad well no first
first he going to pimp he was going to
pimp her out I think he you a sick man
he was tripping on drugs and I don't
know it seemed like the way he was
saying it he was like it was like he was
[__] with him I couldn't I wasn't
sure I think he he was [__] with her
about him I think he was [__] with
him about her so he would get rid of her
that's what I yeah maybe that's what it
was but then he goes we got to get rid
of her [__] she's that's too much
trouble that's a lot of heat the cops
and [__] she's underage
and they just take her to another hotel
and buy her a room and drop her off
there yeah just leave there and just
leave her there she keeps calling back
and they making up stories that the
gangsters are [__]
after they know yeah and they know where
she lives and the [__] they're going
to come get her so it's like you better
all about her and then towards the end
of the movie they're running from the
cops or something and they somebody's
crossing the street in front them they
slam on the breaks it's her she's
walking around with [__] painting
with all her paintings under her arms
and just [__] funny and it's
Christina REI playing it in well what I
heard of the real story it's been a long
time since I read the book but in yeah
she was underage for sure and when um
Hunter S Thompson came into the hotel
room um Dr Gonzo or Oscar was actually
naked yeah so you were led to assume
that he had had sex with her yeah um how
old was she in real life I don't know
didn't say yeah younger than she looked
in the movie I think okay but so in the
movie
you know you could assume that that
might have happened but they actually
kind of put a robe or a moomo type thing
on him so it wouldn't look quite as
scandalous I guess he he was asking her
for a kiss and she's like no no yeah so
I guess they were trying to imply it
without being too you know getting in
too much trouble I guess but I think
like in real life yeah he was totally
naked like when 100 came in the hot room
that's all you know about it that's
pretty much all yeah that's like all I
remember but yeah I know that they kind
of toned it down for the movie a little
bit cuz like I said I know they didn't
want to get in trouble but see the okay
so the thing about this movie is that I
feel like this
was ahead of its time a bit Yeah cuz
this came out the weird thing about it
is that everybody talking about it when
it came out well the weird thing about
it was it was a financial flop yeah um
you know it it was a complete failure it
got like some people really liked it at
the time like it got some okay reviews
but like some people like super hated it
because it were like look nothing
happens 98 okay yeah um so it kind of
got really mixed reviews tending toward
the negative but the weird thing about
it is that I feel like the book when it
came out was like really critically
praised and the movie is pretty close to
what happens in the book maybe like even
softens it a little bit but it's kind of
similar I mean it kind of so it just
seems really weird that people were the
things that people were offended by in
the movie or didn't like about the movie
were kind of the same things that people
tended to like about the book the weird
thing about it was that even the movie
did really bad it got um people
interested in Hunter Thompson again and
his book sales been like way up like
after this movie came out but people
didn't like the movie but the thing
about it is that now it's obviously like
a cult classic so I kind of feel like it
maybe came out too early yeah and I will
note that it does seem that it's still
kind of one of those divisive films
probably less so than when it came out
but because not I'm not going to say
nothing happens in it but it is kind of
like just a road trip drug trip type of
movie so it's very episodic it's not
like a three act structure and there
there were other movies like this just
that they're kind of Forgotten and they
weren't you couldn't take them as
seriously because they weren't based on
reality a good example would be chich
and Chong's movies they were drug trip
movies yeah it's a similar they weren't
based on anything that was real they
were just made made the [__] up there
really wasn't a story there either
getting high and the crazy [__] that
happens and just crazy [__] happening
yeah space Coke and everything you know
the UFOs land and they give [__]
Chong some space Coke and he my dad L
teaching it was funny is that I remember
I remember being a kid yeah listening to
the records the late 70s early 80s and
thinking that [__] was really funny you
can listen to that on YouTube now you
listen it's not funny at all it didn't
age well at all it was funny then it was
funny at the time it was funny at the
time but this [__] is still funny though
I would I would submit yeah because it's
based on [__] that happened yeah this
[__] really happens um you know what I
mean and I know it's a weird thing to
say because this movie is like borders
on surreal yeah but from a subjective
point of view it's based on some [__]
that really happened and it's trying to
give you the experience that they would
have had going through that experience
imagine if Naked Lunch really happened
we got to do that movie too because I
just saw that pop up on one of our
streaming servers maybe on HBO Max or
prime or something like that and I was
like [__] I haven't seen that movie in
so long and it's like I really want to
do that you see naked lunch that's a
movie that's based upon a book called
Naked Lunch that is nothing like the
movie it's just and it's written by
under the influence of all different
kinds of drugs and every three pages the
story is different because he's so high
he can't tell you the stories they made
a a few of the things I could barely get
through it uh a few of the things in the
book a few of the did show up in the
movie kind of like having sex with your
typewriter your typewriter being alive
that was the typewriter turning into a
bug yeah turn yeah that that kind of
stuff was wasn't any snorting bug spray
or bug powder or something yeah I don't
think that was in the book though this
long time that might have been just the
movie Just a
movie but uh that that's a good one too
and if you try to make sense out of that
one you're good luck well see it's not
that it's that's not the kind of
literature that it is that's not the
kind of movie that he was a beat writer
what was that guy's name that wrote that
[__] um uh William S burough William S
buroughs that's right who did all kinds
of nasty [__] in real life him and his
girlfriend yeah well see that's the
thing it's like these kind of movies
that kind of literature stuff like that
you just kind of have to relax and let
it wash over you you can't like get too
you can't get too um concerned about
like whether that's real or or or plot
or it's not you know what I mean it's
experimental yeah so you just kind of
have to take it as it comes which like I
said this is too it does it is a series
of incidents but it's not like a like a
threea structure it's basically just two
guys doing all the drugs and just going
through this and and just [__] getting
worse and worse and worse you know what
I mean and then it kind of now some
people have said and even Terry Gilliam
said this and he said he thought this
about the book too that it doesn't have
a real good ending like the ending is
just kind of it just kind of stops or
it's you know what I mean it's just kind
of abrupt or whatever but I didn't
really mind that though like about the
movie you know no it just it was over
yeah that's just that was the end of the
story yeah you know what I mean
everybody just went everybody just went
back home and went back to their regular
lives like it is when you're get done
with a B yeah that's it's just over I
just I can't imagine cuz who was I think
October wraith was saying before that um
they don't know how they're still alive
because they were on acid in the 70s for
like three years straight or something
yeah what's weird is that uh like when
they were in the hotels sometimes I mean
they have trashed those hotel rooms just
trashed them in one scene it's they Deep
in water and it had to have been a
hallucination
because a [__] hotel room can't hold
that much water it would go through the
floor yeah like I said you can't really
get too concerned about is this really
happening or not it could just be their
perception right I mean it could be well
there was that whole I love that whole
sequence too where Bono Del Toro like Dr
Gonzo is in the tub and he tries to get
Duke to throw the radio in there so he
can hear the the music music better it's
it's Jefferson Airplane was it a radio
yeah okay I thought it was a tape
recorder oh he was trying to was a tape
recorder yeah he sto a tape recorder in
to electrocute him yeah to kill him but
also he wanted to throw he wanted him to
throw it in there like when the music
got to its like ultimate you know what I
mean yeah during when right White Rabbit
way was White Rabbit right when White
Rabbit got when White Rabbit got just
[__] thing and he's like okay I'll
toally but then these two dudes just
tripping and they're trying to help each
other in get through their trips it's
just [__] funny and they just yeah
they just have they trashed so many
hotel rooms they seemingly never got in
trouble though because seem like never
got in trouble it really I mean I know
it was the 70s and it was kind of a more
freewheeling time but I mean
Bon well that's what I mean well so Dr
Gonzo threatened people in the elevator
with a knife including Cameron Diaz um
you know and the other people that were
in there cute ass Cameron Diaz before
she was famous yeah she was up she was
only in like one scene yeah and I forgot
she was in this too yeah but um yeah so
he did that they trashed several hotel
rooms like really trash them um you know
so and they were just like running
around I don't even [__] know pulled
a gun on they they jumped they jumped on
the maid and pulled a gun on that's
right and threatened her to not to tell
anybody they thought she thought they
were narcotics cops yeah for them to get
out of it they pretended to hire her and
make her an informant they said we're
going to call you and send you $1,000
every month she yeah yeah yeah okay they
they recruited her I was like that poor
lady she's going to be like where's my
money it wasn't a gun he was pointing at
he was holding something else like it
was a gun yeah that's what it was yeah
it wasn't a gun it was what was it it
was like a cane or I don't remember what
it was part of yeah it was like I could
part of a shower head or something
something like that but yeah he was
pointed out she was just like totally
rolling with it yeah but they well the
thing about it was that they were at
this other Hotel because after they
didn't really even cover the motorcycle
race that they first got sent out there
to cover then they got another
assignment he got another assignment
where he had to get and cover like a
like a anti-drug
it was like the District Attorney's uh
convention or something and they were
doing like some big anti-drug thing that
scene was also [__] hilarious where
that dude was up there talking about
marijuana addicts and just being
completely clueless about Fu what
[__] drugs did and everything and
they just like couldn't take it because
they're sitting there going oh my God
this dude doesn't know what the [__]
he's talking about but yeah and I mean
Johnny Depp is great in this like I said
I it doesn't surprise me that he lived
with Hunter S Thompson for four months
to get all of his voice and his manner
Ms and everything like that but I think
really Bono Del Toro is the underrated
star star of this movie he just went
balls to the wall yeah crazy oh and also
he gained 45 PBS for this role got fat
yeah he ate 16 donuts a day
damn and Thompson kept calling him a um
Samoan Samo he's not think he was
Mexican the real guy as well as the
actor are Mexican but he just but he
wanted him to be a Samoan he keep
calling him a Samoan well what I heard
was that they changed it to Samoan in
the movie or in the book or that he
changed it to Sone in the book so that
no one would know it was the real person
even though even though it's like
obviously that's who it everybody knew
who it was what was great is that you
know he would say as your lawyer I
recommend you go in there going to mden
cabinet and get those pills and [__]
take making he was making to take judge
take drugs yeah uh using his his powers
as an attorney yeah that's right you I
advise as your lawyer I advise you to
take five and he's like oh I should have
okay okay okay which is that's a great
angle I love I love that he did that one
time and he was saying it serious too
yeah he was totally serious about it
well I mean the kind of cool thing about
it is crazy as this movie is like all
the crazy visuals and all the like all
the [__] that happens like when they're
at that circus casino and [__] like that
like the whole thing with the um uh and
this it it was only a second but I was
just like oh my God that's [__]
brilliant with the trappes artist and
the trappes artist Like Somebody catches
her she's like pregnant and then like
the baby pops out like on the hits with
a sledgehammer belly the baby pops out
on the [__] on the umbilical cord
yeah I was like oh my God that's [__]
great I wish I'd see and that and Terry
gilam I think actually just thought of
that I don't think that was in the book
but I thought that was kind of a cool
idea where the where Hunter S Tom
uh
gono
journalist has justifies to himself that
his attorney must be with him at all
times on all these missions he's got to
have his attorney with him yeah but he's
just his buddy they get high with to get
high with that's need he doesn't need an
attorney he just has to he has to come
up with an excuse why he needs an
attorney to himself I guess I don't know
or just to keep him around so he can get
high and maybe he maybe he could get
drugs easier I don't know maybe he had
maybe he had better connection had
better drug connection
May that's what it was I just this is
drug friend I mean the thing about it is
I feel like I'm amazed that some
people from this era only dudes could
have drug are still
alive I don't think that's the
case I've known girls that had drug
friends yeah I guess so I'm just talking
about two dudes that just hang out so
they could do drugs and just they're
just doing all the drug they doing all
the they're just well I mean I've never
seen two girls hang out just to do drugs
I've seen girls hang out with guys to do
drugs there just strawberries you know
yeah
but two dudes just hanging out doing
drugs well like you said before dude's
friendship seem very like well well they
seem very kind of like um activity
centered yeah whatever that whether it's
video games or taking Adrena Chrome or
whatever it happens to be um that's
that's just your friend for that yeah
that's this is this is the friend that I
go to strip clubs and go visit hookers
with yeah um you know so it's just kind
of like that's very funny that you have
like a friend for each activity yeah
that's that's your that activity you got
gun friends motorcycle friends hooker
friends yeah who are your hooker friends
I don't have hooker friend I don't have
hooker yeah not anymore back in the Army
had all kinds of I was going to say you
got to say that now are you get in
trouble
anymore a hooker friend but yeah I was
what I was to say is that dudes like
this I can't believe and even what you
were saying October wreath it's like um
cuz they were saying I'm not sure how
I've lived this long but I did acid for
about 3 years straight in the' 70s then
came cocaine and everything else now I
just smoke bud and cigarettes and beers
honestly I can't imagine like how
because the drugs I feel like were a lot
stronger back then and people took a lot
more of them USD
was so I don't even know how some people
all accounts they didn't have a dose
right like one hit was equivalent to
like four hits back then maybe
more now a hit a hit of acid is on paper
is controllable it's not yeah I mean it
wasn't yeah like it was effective yeah
but it wasn't I wasn't seeing like rims
full of lizards or anything you take you
take a whole album cover which is four
of them because it used to be that four
of them had made album cover the album
cover a lot of time was dark side of the
moon well of course yeah of course
sometimes did see I did see uh some lead
Zeppelin ones too houses of the Holy oh
yeah that's a good one too if you took
all four of them you you were trashed
you were you [__] that was a lot that
was enough you're on the
moon you
know you know how you know how it's
where you you can still deal with
reality yeah not on four yeah on four
you're gonna have to stay at home cuz I
was still I mean you know we didn't go
anywhere right on it but um
I could still I still was lucid enough
yeah to know that what I was seeing it's
like oh well that's real but that's
probably not real you know what I mean
like weird [__] that I was seeing like
so I wasn't freaking out about it
anything it was so I I just kind of kept
my wits about me mostly yeah we used to
drive on it in high school yeah see I
can't imagine yeah we could drive on it
but I don't even like driving on I don't
even like driving when I'm completely
sober you had to let it wear off you had
to let it wear off well I hope as it
started to wear down you drive well on
you could drive on that a lot better
than you could on alcohol well I you
know what if you have to be on something
to drive which I'd rather you weren't um
probably I would pick acid over alcohol
cuz at least you acid at least you kind
of know you're Lucid like I said alcohol
you're just like blah whatever you know
what I mean and your reflexes are okay
right yeah and alcohol you're just
like like at least I am um yeah they're
talking about yeah Camp guys said said I
tried to read Naked Lunch it was
incomprehensible and then High Desert
said yeah burough is just unreadable
yeah I can't read it Camp guy said James
Joy's ulyses is pretty hard to
understand but at least it's partially
accessible yeah I found it's out there
but yeah you can understand parts of it
um yeah Zan said about this movie it's a
great movie it aged really well yeah I
think I think it did too oh yeah you
could you it's still funny you could
watch this once a year yeah it's still
funny it's great and I and I love the
visuals like the visuals are so cool and
like I said when I read about the
cinematographer what was his name uh
Nicola perone pone something like that
um he only has one eye the
cinematographer um well he had retinal
cancer okay so he had one of his eyes
removed I guess and uh so he only has
one he's a oneeyed cinematographer but
he they had the idea they're like every
single different drug we're going to do
a slightly different so we're going to
use like wide angle lens for certain
things or we're going to use like you
know different filters where like colors
bleed into one another like when they're
on masculin or whatever so it'll look
kind of more like the experience of
being on each one you know what I mean
it's like some some of the shots they
wanted it to look more like
claustrophobic like the walls were
closing in and things like that but yeah
it's it's just a great it's a great
movie I mean like I said I can see how
some people might not like it because
it's not a standard if you're a square
narrative if you're a square you're not
going to like this movie but it's just
like a fun yeah just like look at these
crazy people like what the [__] they did
all these crazy drugs it's just kind of
hilarious and if you've never done of
those drugs this is a good example it
might make you not want to do them yeah
or it might make you really want to do
them I'm not really sure and it make you
know what the effects are like it
depends on what kind of person you are
why somebody's acting that way you know
right but you know what the effects are
like uh High Desert said didn't people
complain that Depp was miscast as
Thompson I think people did at the time
but it's crazy because Hunter as
Thompson after he met Johnny Depp he
said I can't think of anyone else who
would play who could play me yeah and
like I said he actually lived there and
he actually ended up really liking they
said at the Terry Gilliam said at the
premiere like Hunter ass Thompson came
to the premiere like to watch the movie
and when they were when he was watching
the movie they said he was acting like
he was reliving it all again there like
he was making all of this noise like he
was on a roller coaster ride like oh the
bats and all that other kind of [__]
like he was remembering like having
[__] ass black or something and like
Terry Gil thought that was so cool he's
like oh I guess we captured it if it's
like back all those memories cuz he was
like reacting like oh my God like you
know what I mean like he was reliving it
again that was like so [__] funny to
me um yeah Camp guy Terry gilam the only
American member of Monty Python yeah
that's right and I he he makes like the
coolest [__] movies man like
especially like visually all his movies
look like super cool I've reviewed a few
of them myself but did we ever review um
what was that movie Time Bandits did we
ever do Time Bandits I don't think we
reviewed it no oh we ought to I love
that movie I love that movie we saw it a
couple years ago I think didn't we yeah
I think we yeah because I used to see it
all the time like on cable and I [__]
loved that movie when I was growing up
think I had a hard time following it or
something um you kind of got to pay
attention because it kind of goes but it
jumps well you know it's about they go
like different time periods another one
I haven't seen in a while and I want to
review it was I want to review Brazil
yeah we need to do that yeah I remember
really liking that one weeview that I
don't think we did maybe we did but if
we did it was a long time ago
um yeah Camp guy said oh Tammy says
there's a YouTube channel ninja versus
Samurai and it has Lone Wolf and Cub TV
series okay yeah I heard oh yeah all
right yeah we should check that out
where's this now it's a YouTube channel
YouTube channel ninja versus Samurai
okay that's cool man I love Lone Wolf I
got movies The Lone Wolf and Cub movies
yeah Jen gave me like the deluxe [__]
Criterion Edition oh it's beautiful I
think it's six movies
yeah and it's like in this big like
unfolding thing with all this gorgeous
artwork on it and all this like looks
like Japanese old paper you know phots I
love it I love packaging you know it's
I'm a graphic designer so I get I I get
little squee about packaging I've seen
those movies once I should go back and
watch them again yeah I think we did a
big like um we did a big massive review
on all of them I thought did we do them
one at a time or maybe we did them all
at
once probably did them all at once you
had to go back and check either that we
just talked about it yeah maybe Camp guy
said I have had one good Acid Trip the
walls were waving and the colors were
all neon orange and blue that's out of
maybe five or 10 total acid experiences
that acid must have been killer strong
it was like nothing I've ever
experienced before nice too not a bad
trip at
all yeah um I I didn't see anything
crazy you know what I mean mostly
everything was just kind of moving and
like all the colors were like super
bright um some of like digital numbers
like on the oven and the clock and stuff
looked like they were in Chinese that
kind that kind of stuff so it wasn't
like too crazy you know what I mean um
yeah Zan said Hunter us Thompson
actually is a cameo in this movie yeah
that's right he does he's um yeah he's
the guy that's doing acid in the
bathroom that's right I didn't see it
didn't know and when I forgot like there
were some other cameos in here too flee
was in it first second yeah Lyall love
it is in it for a second um who else is
in this we already said Toby Maguire cuz
I had forgotten like that there was all
these like yeah I had forgotten like all
these super famous people were in it and
I was just like oh my God that's like
really that's crazy yeah Zanna said I
heard Brazil was good but I've never
seen it it's good yeah it's about um it
has nothing to do with
Brazil it just has has to do with a uh
real kind of
like backwards um it's a guy he who
works in a
Ministry that government min Ministry
that uh censors old newspapers and stuff
yeah oh Danny said yeah we reviewed it
we did review it yeah I thought we did
it's kind of like 1984 it's a despotic
kind of
type socialist regime where there's real
rich people who run everything and
everybody else is just kind of
like real Monday and
uh there was a Revolution going on he
falls in love with a girl who was in
that Revolution he ends up getting
tortured and stuff it's and he's uh
having this he's he's kind of kind of
like Walter midi where he has his normal
life but then he has a fantasy life
where he's got he's dealing with like
idealized versions of himself and other
people it's a good flick Rober jiro's in
it uh he plays a terrorist who his job
is to fix people's pipes Plumbing in
violation of [__] government
ordinance it's just weird man because
the main enemy was
bureaucracy so you were a terrorist if
you went around the bu bureaucracy
pretty cool it's kind of Comedy too yeah
it's like a black comedy like black
comedy yeah but um yeah I thought we'
reviewed it I thought it sounded like
familiar and I knew that we'd watched it
not too like a few years ago few years
ago so I thought yeah but I'm trying to
think of like whe what other Terry gilam
have we I know I reviewed Tiel land
probably last year
but I can't remember what other Terry
Gillian we did but I don't think we've
done Time Bandits but maybe we did I
have to look it up yeah Ben says one of
Terry Gillam's best films like 1984 on
acid yeah he must be talking about
Brazil brail yeah Zan said Brazil holds
a 98% rating on Rotten Tomatoes yeah
it's one of those movies that pretty
much everybody agrees is [__] awesome
real deep wellmade
artistic got a lot of uh messaging in it
it's good
Ben says Baron munchow yeah we
definitely have not done Baron munchow
The Adventures of Baron munchow but I
would like to do that because that's a
[__] that was a trip also he's made a
lot of really good movies Terry Gilliam
all right so are you ready to wrap it up
yeah oh Danny said yeah you did Review
Time Bandits oh okay okay see I'm Lista
we've we've done so many movies that
that I forget like which ones we maybe
we should do Naked Lunch next I just
keep seeing it like I'm streaming and
I'm like I kind of want want to watch
that again nicked lunch is [__]
surreal I liked it yeah I remember
really I watched it cuz me and my friend
me and my friend whose name is also Jen
back in the 80s and 90s we used to rent
movies like all the like every weekend
and we always liked really weird [__] so
it's like we watched all the weird [__]
like from back then that stars the dude
that played Robocop what's his name yeah
yeah yeah what's that guy's name yeah I
forgot his name dud play RoboCop Peter
Peter Weller Peter well he plays the
writer yeah he's having sex with his
insectoid [__]
typewriter yeah and all the yeah and
like other things happen everything
turns alive he has sex with it it's
weird man that's probably what would
really happen if like like everything
just comes to life dude like you know
what I'm gonna [__] it yeah he's
snorting insecticide like a drug yeah
yeah it's pretty crazy it's crazy
[__] movie maybe we should do that
next week cuz like I said I keep seeing
it like I I don't remember what
streaming service it's on one of the
ones that I look at all the time and I'm
just like a I haven't seen that movie in
so long I remember really liking yeah
it's all practical effects as wild yeah
cuz I think that's from the 90s too
isn't it yeah if I if I remember
correctly it's been a while Zano said
you guys haven't reviewed Brazil I
checked we haven't okay oh all right I
could have sworn that we did okay maybe
we did Time Bandits but not like I said
I know I did tide land but I did that by
myself so I don't know I don't know
we'll we'll see what we can see and like
I said maybe we'll do Naked Lunch
because I kind of want to watch it again
uh but yeah all right so everybody have
a Happy New Year's Day uh you know
hopefully your first day of 2024 was
good um we will be back on Wednesday
night for our Regular Show we're going
to do military mishaps yeah so remember
because you were talking about the plane
that dropped the atomic bombs on North
Carolina all that kind of stuff so we'll
talk about that kind of stuff I mostly
kind of want to talk about kind of ones
that are funnier yeah but uh maybe
people died but it was still kind of
funny just cuz it was like so ridiculous
but I don't know if you have any
recommendations for what I should cover
then let me know cuz I have a bunch that
I set aside but we'll see how that goes
now tomorrow I might don't hold me to
this I might put up my history of horror
video tomorrow because it's all recorded
um I'm just working on editing it at the
moment so if I get it edited then I'll
put it up tomorrow but if not then I'll
probably put it up Thursday but it'll be
up this week for sure because I got it
all
recorded and I got most of the stuff
kind of working on I just have to kind
of put all the pieces together you know
what I mean which takes a while but
we'll see how that goes but you know all
right so have a good evening you guys
and we'll see you guys again on
Wednesday night good night